let's start with by-election shall we
Stratford and ermston already a labor
seat but the tourists have seen a big
cut in their share of the vote haven't
they so should they be worried at all by
that yes clearly they should be but this
is one of those results Murray very good
analysis just now where the result
itself is no surprise each of the
parties can say well it was good for us
labor got to 70 and that's a very
challenging figure the conservatives
went down by 12 percent which is
actually less than the opinion polls
we're indicating and there's a smaller
swing than two weeks ago at the jester
by-election which we discussed here so
it's
disappointing but not bad for the
conservatives pleasing for the labor
party very low turnout often you see
protest votes at by-elections midterm
don't you so how much can we read into
this as far as a general election is
concerned very little
by-elections as you say people register
protest votes if you look back at swings
in other parliaments swings in this
Parliament I've just referred to Chester
we've had Wakefield they were larger
swings than this swing against the
government this is mid-range and in most
cases the seats then revert back to the
party that held it previously if they
change hands so nothing astonishing in
relation to this swing quite normal well
some of the Tory MPS nearby It's a grand
Brady for example very close by will
they be feeling a little bit anxious I
think Mr Graham and other local MPS will
be feeling anxious because of problems
in terms of local elections that have
been going on for several years there's
been a friend away from the
conservatives in that belt of South
South and West Manchester so yes they
will be concerned but as Murray
indicated you've got the local elections
next May and people will be looking has
the government solved the industrial
relations issues is inflation coming
down it started coming down this week is
the government considered to be a
credible
manager in terms of issues such as the
Northern Ireland protocol well yes and
on the issue of strikes obviously people
have been seeing them over the last few
weeks they've got weeks stretching ahead
of industrial action on the calendar
what is that doing to the government's
reputation and Rishi sunax image as a
prime minister in control does it look
like that is being damaged the LCN
clearly one doesn't want to dispute with
any part of the NHS that's a very
difficult problem
um in terms of judgments for a general
election where a year and a half two
years away from a general election the
other issues like the railways Etc we're
in a very difficult post-covered set of
circumstances it's difficult to manage
because they're coming all at the same
time but the polls are actually showing
an erosion of support still General
support for the trade unions but an
erosion of that support as they run on
and particularly the rail unions
striking over Christmas and therefore
keeping families apart but what about
the the health strikes that the nurse is
going out on strike how difficult is
that for Rishi sunak and how much has he
got the party on board on this we read
in the papers this morning that there
are four former ministers who are
calling for the pay review body which
the government is Keen to stress they're
following their recommendations they're
saying you need to go back to them
because that's out of date now before I
went into the Lords I used to spend my
time negotiating with trade unions on
the management side so I've negotiated
with most of the major trade unions over
many years and people from outside the
negotiations pontificating about what
should be done always used to irritate
me and so I'm not going to start doing
it and I'm talking here about management
colleagues who were not involved in the
negotiations leave it to the negotiators
leave it they have to report to the
prime minister to the head of the RCN
and the like but it can't go on an
excessive length of time because that
will stretch The credibility of the
Prime Minister because disputes in the
NHS are not what any government wants
well yes and do you think that the
government can stick to its current line
or does it is it going to have to shift
its position do you think I I as I say
having spent many years negotiating the
answer is I don't know it's in the
position of looking inwards it's getting
the advice from the negotiators it's
getting the advice from the health
secretary it they'll make a judgment on
a day-by-day basis and the general
argument is we haven't got the money to
give in to these paid demands but also
they're saying if we pay inflation
meeting or busting pay Rises that in
itself is inflationary do you think that
message cuts through to the public I
think in part it cuts through but not
there is a natural sympathy towards the
Health Service unions which makes it
more difficult to negotiate with their
the pay board which is what the health
secretary is referring to very clearly
made a recommendation the people you
referred to as saying well look at it it
was several months ago it was
pre-invasion of Ukraine pre-gas prices
and the like so it's going to be a
difficult one to tackle the other one
other trade disputes the likes of the
railways for example and Civil Service
much more easy to do deal with even the
rail unions working from home is so much
easier now that actually the impact is
far less than it might have been a few
years ago and what about the impact on
labor of strikes Richie Cena very keen
whenever he can to to to paint the
unions as as being in the control of
Union Barons he talks about Labor then
being Labor's payment unions being
Labor's pay masters I mean to what
extent is that effective do you think in
trying to shift some of the blame for
the strikes off the tourists oh there's
no question that it is the natural
tactic of the conservatives of the
government is to show the labor party in
the hands of the of the bar the union
Barons whether that cuts through heavily
or not I'm not sure but kirstam is
walking a fine line because he said
labor MPS labor spokesmen should not be
going on the picket lines and some have
done and whether they're spokesman or
spokeswomen they they are facing an
issue themselves it's a fine line for
both sides but it's a bigger problem for
the government than it is for the
opposition